the beat the page the new chapter
history is a resource to hit it
[music]
europe separates the season 5 scenario for
the european union of the 27
we can go ahead directing all our
energies towards achieving results in
important areas and so
positively agreeing the agenda  created the
fashionable 1100 banks
we could also attack the opposite
way and limit ourselves from European
127 exclusively to the domestic market
then for the group of 27
cannot reach an agreement neither
firmly many nor the ways to get there
then that should want to
make progress in the various areas over the years  be
allowed
to make further progress but where
users get it, there
is still a possibility the
eu-27 could decide to do more together in
a somewhat smaller office building of
area united, the
co-creators can also decide
to share more powers and resources and make
more decisions together  to meet
you could go full throttle without taboo
the present level definitely the
commission
draws a positive balance the woman
through discounts few local monthly
university press series the magicians
through and germania to realize
madrid wants kaká the europeans here on
web based devices restaurant as well as
photos watch  the live dvd of controversies
are could leave these children wb.com
[music]